Ashton is in Washington DC
hey Ashton how are you I'm a mess but
I'm okay how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up so I think I'm just
panicking but I am $80,000 in debt and I
have to move out of my in-laws house by
the end of the month about 60 thousand
of that is in cars and then we're making
a household income on my face salary
60,000 Wow okay so you went into the
land of stupid on cars big time didn't
you extremely yeah so how far upside
down are you on the two cars on my
wife's car about 25,000 upside down in a
much talk about tents all set of 25,000
did you say we need a car in about three
years I'm sorry and the interest rates
over 22% we've had the car for about
three years interest rates over 22% yeah
but then okay but I mean you must have
traded some negative equity into that
car yes sir so my wife we weren't
married at the time but so my it's
actually under my in-laws but my wife
was driving an old and pole and that
blew up they owed about ten thousand on
it so they rolled over about seven
thousand legs of equity into the vehicle
mm-hmm whose name is this car in her
father's okay so her father has a card
that yes but we have to make the poem
okay but her father had a bad car deal
and now you're supposed to take care of
the bad car deal yes sir that doesn't
make sense
his Impala was it was a screwed-up deal
and so you guys are supposed to pay the
amount that he's upside-down well it was
it was my wife's car it's his name but
it's her vehicle she was under 18 so she
couldn't get a loan so he went got the
loan for her you know
hmm I don't like these people um well
you're gonna have to sell the car and
you're gonna be both of them and you're
gonna have to go get loans to cover the
difference is your credit okay 50 Oh God
you need to start looking for loans
because both of these cars have to be
gone they're both ridiculous and hold on
we're gonna put you guys in Financial
Peace University and you need to start
talking your father in law he needs to
eat some of this car because it's his
fault he put his teenaged daughter into
a well and now he wants her husband to
get him get her out that's not a good
plan